the fastest way to accomplish any goal
is to model success find someone who's
already done what you're trying to do
and put their strategies to work for you
success leaves clues if you have the eye
to follow it if you don't you're going
to spend countless hours time dollars
energy resources going down the wrong
path and on a path that doesn't serve
you my favorite famous entrepreneur is a
man who died 30 years before I was born
his name was EP Giannini and he was a
founder of Bank of America and when
people hear this they say Bank of
America really you like a banker of all
the options you could pick from you
chose a banker and for me it's different
because he was the banker of the little
guy he believed in the little guy and
that's something that really resonated
with me and what I'm trying to do with
my business he liked helping
hard-working immigrants and he liked
helping entrepreneurs when nobody else
would believe in them he got into
banking and as he was on the board of a
bank and he said bankers typically only
support businesses and rich people why
don't we support the little guys and
they said no so he opened up his own
bank across the street from the bank
that he was at literally across the
street and he supported the
entrepreneurs and the hard-working
immigrants and he lent money to people
based on a handshake a signature and a
look on their face really a look on
their face and a handshake what kind of
banker even today what kind of banker
would do that it's crazy but that's what
he did and he gained a cult-like status
amongst entrepreneurs and immigrants
when a young man named Walt Disney got
laughed out of every banker's office
because he wanted to turn cartoons into
full feature length films they thought
it was crazy so he went to go see AP
Giannini and ap gave him the money he
needed to launch his first movie and
later on go on and build an empire and
that's the kind of stuff that he did and
reading those stories and learning from
his strategies and his success not only
gives me specific ideas of what I can do
but also gives me the motivation to keep
going and that's the power of modeling
success so whatever goal you have
whatever challenge you're facing right
now
somebody has already done it they've
already accomplished it they've already
solved it and they may have died decades
ago like my idol did you just have to
find them and following their success
will not only give you specific ideas
and strategies what you can do to
overcome your challenge but also give
you the motivation and guidance to keep
going and doing it while in success is
the fastest way to accomplish any goal
that you have and I hope that you'll
apply it to your business as soon as
possible good luck